Hi, I'm Melissa Villaseñor,
and I do voice impressions.
For example,
this is Kristen Wiig
about to go skydiving.
“I changed my mind.
I'm, I'm scared, I'm scared
I'll get stuck on a cloud,
and then I’ll have to
become an angel.”
(Laughter and applause)
Thanks.
This is Sandra Bullock
if she were to knock over
a bunch of dominoes.
Just pretend they're here in the room.
“No, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no.”
That's it.
(Laughter)
She always does that in movies.
And this is Lady Gaga
if she gave birth to a baby
in "A Star is Born."
(Vocalizing)
(Vocalizing baby crying)
(Applause and laughter)
Miss Gaga, a star is born.
(Laughter)
And this is Melissa Villaseñor
giving a TED Talk.
Hi, I'm Melissa Villaseñor
and I do voice impressions.
(Laughter)
A little bit about me.
Born and raised
in Los Angeles, California,
to a Mexican-American family.
Middle child, OK, I was very shy.
I didn't do the best in school,
but I was very observant,
maybe a little creepy.
And I realized I had this superpower
of doing voice impressions
when I was 12 years old.
And it all began with the pop
singers at that time, OK.
Britney Spears:
“All you people look at me
like I’m a little girl.”
I know, spooky.
(Laughter)
And hot.
I should do that all the time, huh?
(Laughter)
I sang a lot of Shakira back then, just,
“There’s a she wolf in the closet.”
And I was kind of wolf-like singing at 13,
you know, hairy, puberty days.
(Laughter)
I looked up to Gwen Stefani
in high school.
I loved Gwen Stefani from No Doubt,
and I wanted to look like her.
So I shaved my eyebrows
real thin to copy her,
like in the "Return of Saturn"
days, that Gwen.
And I thought, "Oh, my friends
at school must think
I look just like Gwen Stefani."
I probably looked more like It, the clown.
It was spooky, thin, just,
“I kinda always knew
I’d end up looking like It.”
(Laughter)
I loved making my friends laugh
at school with my voices.
And I suddenly wasn't so shy anymore.
I felt like, oh, this is why I'm here.
This is my purpose,
to bring joy and laughs.
And I suddenly got obsessed
with Saturday Night Live at 15 years old.
And I was so determined, I was like,
I'm going to become a comedian
and I'm going to get on the cast
of Saturday Night Live.
So right after high school, I graduate,
I go straight to signing up
for open mic shows in Hollywood.
My parents went straight
to worrying for their daughter.
(Laughter)
Now I went to junior college for them.
You know, I went for, like,
a quarter or a semester.
I don't know, I wasn't there
long enough to find out.
(Laughter)
But thankfully I got amazing opportunities
pretty early on in my career
because I think it was rare to see
a female voice impressionist
at comedy clubs.
And a cute one.
(Laughs)
(Laughter)
But I got the opportunity
to be on “America’s Got Talent”
season six in 2011.
I'm not going to lie,
I killed it, OK, 90 seconds.
I did a bunch of impressions, just,
Barbara Walters.
I did a Natalie Portman
from the "Black Swan."
I did a Sarah Silverman.
Wanda Sykes.
I did Miley Cyrus.
And Christina Aguilera, oh, oh.
(Laughter)
From that exposure, being on that show,
I was able to quit my part-time job
and become a headlining comedian
around the country
for clubs and colleges.
Now, that's amazing if you've been
doing stand up for a while,
but I only had ten minutes
and suddenly I had to do an hour
at comedy club.
So I bombed a lot.
I cried in a lot of hotels
around the country.
But I noticed something
as I was on the road,
working on jokes and performing,
I noticed that everyone was laughing
at all the impression bits.
But every time I tried to talk
about myself and my life, my family,
it didn't get laughs
and it was starting to bug me.
People will come up to me
after shows and they would go,
"Oh, I love your Owen Wilson impression.
He's so funny."
And I'd say, "Thanks,"
but inside I'd be like,
"Wait, do they only like me
for my Owen Wilson impression, wow?
That really bums me out, man."
(Laughter)
So at that point I became
determined again.
I was like, no, I'm going
to write about myself.
I want to find my own voice
among the voices that I do
because I think it's important
and it's special,
and I think it's the best
feeling to connect
as your true self with other people.
(Laughs)
(Applause)
And, you know, thankfully,
I did find a voice.
Yeah, a funny-sounding one,
but a voice.
And I like making fun of things in life.
It just makes life
a little easier to handle.
I like making fun of my energy.
It's not sexy.
You feel it.
(Laughter)
My energy is a lot like a proud dad's.
No wonder relationships don't work out.
Because every time I go on a date,
I check out the dude, first thing I go,
"Man, look at you."
(Laughter)
"Ah, you look good.
Is that a new jacket?
You look really sharp, my boy."
(Laughter)
"Here's 20 bucks.
Don't tell your mom, go ahead."
(Laughter)
I like talking about how
I'm Mexican, you know?
And I don't look it,
a lot of people don't believe me.
All my life, people would say,
"Oh, you're Mexican?
You don't look Mexican."
And I get so apologetic, I'm like,
"Oh, I'm so sorry, I forgot my sombrero.
Oh, man.
Did I not roll my Rs enough? Sorry."
And I just have to salsa away.
(Laughter)
I know, exterior, you wouldn't believe it,
but just know that inside ...
A lot of piñatas in here.
(Laughter)
I bleed Tapatío.
You know, I don't speak Spanish.
I was a lazy kid,
second generation Mexican,
I didn't work on it.
I know, shame on me.
Or as you would say in Spanish ...
I don't know.
(Laughter)
I have been working on my Spanish though,
because there's a lot of relatives of mine
that only speak in Spanish.
And I think back when I would hang out
with my great grandma, my abuelita,
you know, I would just nod
and smile and wave at her.
How rude.
But she didn't mind, she would just stare
at me lovingly, you know.
I'd be like, "Hey, abuelita, how are you?"
“Ay.”
(Speaking in Spanish)
Thanks, you’re bonita, too.
(Laughter)
"Ay."
And then she'd start talking
crap about me in Spanish.
(Speaking in Spanish)
(Laughs)
(Laughter)
I know I’m loca. You too, huh?
"No, me no."
(Laughter)
(Speaking in Spanish)
What? The tone changed.
What are you two saying over here?
I don’t like this. Why are you sad now?
(Speaking in Spanish)
What is that, boyfriend?
I don’t want one right now, I’m free.
(Speaking in Spanish)
(Laughter)
Fair enough.
See, I like imitating my family
and talking about them,
because that'll never get old,
that's always a part of me.
Celebrities, I don't even
know them, you know?
But this means so much to me.
I like imitating my mom,
she's a funny character.
When I'm driving my car
and she's in the passenger seat,
she's a backseat driver,
she comments on my driving,
and she knows it pisses me off.
So she whispers everything
about my driving,
which is like, that's worse.
Everything sounds so dirty
to my innocent ears.
I'm driving,
she's in the passenger seat
holding on to that rail, you know.
She's pressing --
I didn't know there was
a brake pedal on that side
because she is pressing it, she's just --
(Breathes sharply through teeth)
(Whispering) "Slow down."
(Laughter)
(Whispering) "Oh, you're going too fast."
(Whispering) "Oh, we're not in a rush."
(Laughter)
(Whispering) "Oh, my back."
"Oh, there's a spot right there,
right there, right there,
right there, oh."
(Laughter)
"You missed it."
Ew, nasty.
(Laughter)
Now, after nine years in my journey,
I did get the chance to audition
for Saturday Night Live in 2016,
and I get cast on the show.
(Cheers and applause)
It was so beautiful
to be on the show and magical,
I felt like I entered ...
I mean, my dream, it was real.
It was ...
It was beautiful.
And being on SNL amplified
everything I ever wanted,
especially for doing voices.
Now, I left SNL after six seasons
on the show, just recently,
because, one,
I wasn't strong enough anymore
to handle the pressure of the show.
Two,
I wasn't having fun anymore
looking up celebrities.
And three, there was something inside me,
inside Meliss, that was saying,
there's more to discover about myself,
there's more talents,
there's more things
to learn, to expand on.
So now I'm in a funny position
because I did the --
Evil laugh.
(Imitates evil laugh)
(Laughter)
No, but it is a funny position I'm in
because that was the goal
I worked for since 15
and it's so like, now, like, what do I do?
Has anyone here reached a life goal
and still have years left?
(Laughter and applause)
There was one day recently, I Googled
"What the hell do Olympians do
after they go to the Olympics?"
Just because I want to know
other people that feel this way.
I did find out on Google,
Olympians become teachers and mentors.
And I thought,
"Well, eff that. I don't want to do that."
(Laughter)
The thing I noticed
within the six years of being on SNL,
there was something --
the best stuff that I did
were pieces where I was doing
my impressions,
but I was also very much being Melissa.
So as I go forth in my journey,
I've got to remember to always share
the gifts that I have of doing voices
and also make sure I could be
vulnerable and be myself.
So something I love to share
at my standup shows is
how I struggle with low self-esteem,
and I constantly have to tell myself
positive talk and affirmations.
Now I don't use my voice.
No, I sound too sarcastic,
I don't believe me.
(Laughter)
If I say, "I'm good
at what I do, I'm funny."
I don't ... no.
Thankfully, I have
a Dolly Parton impression,
so I say my affirmations as Dolly.
Works way better.
“I’m good at what I do.
I work hard.”
(Laughter)
(Singing) I work nine to five.
What a way to make a living.
More like 10 minutes
because I’m doing a TED Talk.
(Cheers and applause)
So I hope the lesson
or thing you leave with
is that I hope you could put
your masks down, your personas,
and be your true, true self
because man, it rocks.
Maybe learn a Dolly impression
so you could look in the mirrorm
and say, "I am brave, I am beautiful."
Or better yet, learn
your Melissa impression
so you can look in the mirror and say,
"Man, look at you.
Yeah, you're cool."
Muchas gracias, thank you.
(Cheers and applause)